Today, uh we will be discussing the
second um American Civil War.
So, I want to make the you the argument
that um
a conflict is very likely.
And so, we'll be discussing why it's
likely,
how this war will manifest manifests
itself, and what will happen after this
war, okay?
So,
the first thing to know about America
is that it is a country
that
enjoys violence, okay? You can You can
say that Americans
are addicted
to violence.
Okay, so for example, America has
guns. Uh sorry, 434 million guns.
That's 1.3 guns for every one person.
And the guns they have, a lot of them
are like semi-machine guns, okay? So,
it's a very
um gun-obsessed society.
Not only that, but they believe that gun
ownership is their sacred right
as Americans.
So, the Second Amendment of the
Constitution is that every American has
the right to bear arms.
Um then there's American football.
Have you guys seen uh American football
where guys just bang at each other,
okay? It is It is extremely violent
sport. In fact, America is really the
only country that plays the sport. And
Americans love football. The Super Bowl
is the most watched um
TV event
every year.
And um
the game the game of football causes a
lot of psychological injuries, okay? So,
um there are a lot of football players
who at age 30, they either commit
suicide or they will kill someone
because their brains have been destroyed
by the game, okay? It is It is extremely
violent sport, and even though it is
barbaric, Americans uh love it.
Uh Americans also
worship their history of wars, okay?
They believe that fighting wars it's
noble and it's sacred. Okay, so
second thing to know about America is
that it has a long history
of fighting wars. In fact, you can make
the argument that America has been
continuously at war
since its founding in 1776,
okay? Even before that.
Um so, the first major war that America
fought, of course, was the revolution,
right? 17 1776
War of Independence.
And um
the reality is that Americans believe
this war was sacred,
and uh it was a revolution in human
affairs. But if you actually look at the
history of this war, you discover that
the Americans didn't really fight this
war for good reason.
Um they fought this war because the
British were taxing them.
But if you think about it, well, the
British were providing defense. They
were providing a army, right?
So, the British had a very good reason
to tax the Americans. But the Americans
didn't really like this, so they
rebelled, okay?
Um and the rebellion was actually the
first American Civil War because there
were actually a lot of Americans who
wanted to remain in the Union.
And so,
um these loyalists, a lot of them were
terrorized by extremists who wanted
independence.
Okay, so that is the American uh
uh revolution.
But after the American Revolution, the
Americans embarked on something called
Manifest
Destiny.
And the idea of Manifest Destiny is that
it is God's will that America controls
all of the Americas, okay? North America
and South America. So, the Americans
embarked on a violent
colonization of all lands, okay? Killing
many natives and other peoples
to uh control uh America, okay? Manifest
Destiny.
And then this led to in from 1861
to 1865
the American Civil War, okay? Which
killed
800,000 a million Americans, okay? But
it it was the deadliest war that America
ever fought, okay? Much more so than
World War II and World War I. In fact,
more people died in this war than in war
than in World War I and World War II
combined for America.
All right? And if you look at the reason
for the Civil War, again, you're like,
they didn't actually have to fight this
war, okay? So,
at the founding of the nation, America
was divided into north
and south.
And the difference is that north the
north
um was very industrial.
And the south was agricultural.
Okay? And because the economies were
different, um
the way they structured their politics
and culture and society were different.
So, the north believed in
free labor.
Meaning that you were free to do any job
you want, and employers were free to
hire anyone they wanted. And this system
is obviously much more efficient because
it's an it's a much better use of
manpower. And so, this caused the north
to prosper and become very very wealthy
and expanded, okay? So, at the start of
uh the Civil War in 1861, the north had
a population of 22 million people.
Okay, very wealthy, very powerful. The
south was an agricultural
um
uh was an agricultural-based economy,
and therefore it had to rely on slave
labor.
All right?
Um and even though slave labor made
wealthy people very prosperous, it was
not good for the economy as a whole,
okay? It was an inefficient use of
manpower. And at the start of the war,
they only had about 9 million people.
Okay? But what's important to remember
is that the north was an an
industrial-based economy, the south was
an agricultural-based economy. So, in
terms of weapons manufacturing, in terms
of logistics, in terms of organization,
the north had a huge advantage over the
south.
All right? Now,
Now, why did they fight the war?
And the standard explanation is because
the north wanted to get rid of the evil
of slavery. And that's not true. That's
not what happened.
Um so, at the beginning of the founding
of the nation, the Constitution
permitted
uh slavery, okay? Slavery was legal.
And
um
so, the south were free to have as many
slaves as they want. The north didn't
want didn't need slaves because because
it was an industrial-based
um economy. The problem was the nation
was expanding westwards, okay? The
nation was expanding west. And they were
adding more states into the Union.
And the more states there are, um they
can send senators and representatives to
Washington D.C., okay? And the fear was
then that would tip the balance in favor
of the pro-slavery
uh camp. But if the reverse were true,
if the western states were anti-slavery,
then the south the south would be
marginalized, okay? So, for decades,
there's this fierce debate as to how to
handle um these western states as they
were admitted into the Union one by one,
okay?
And the solution, what they call the
Missouri Compromise, is that for every
one state that came in as pro-slavery,
the other state the next state had to be
anti-slavery, okay? Does that make
sense? To maintain the balance.
But the problem, of course, is that a
lot of these western states had their
own opinions.
So,
um the western So, some of these western
states, for example, Kansas, would would
would want to be anti-slavery, okay?
So, for decades, this was a huge issue
politically
um in America, which divided the nation.
The turning point was in 1860
when Abraham Lincoln
was elected president of the United
States.
And Lincoln was radically anti-slavery.
He believed that slavery was evil and
had to be abolished at some point.
Okay? The rest of the world abolished
slavery. Why is it in America there are
so many slaves?
So, that was Lincoln's agenda.
But Lincoln was also a lawyer,
and he believed that the south legally
had a right to slavery.
But over time what we can do is limit
slavery in the West and therefore over
time and maybe a hundred years time
slavery would naturally cease to exist.
Okay? That was Lincoln's plan.
Now the South did not like this plan and
they were afraid of what Lincoln might
really do
as president so they declared
independence
from the United States. It was they
basically seceded
from the Union, okay? And Lincoln
responds invaded
the South.
Okay?
So basically the Civil War was
a battle over how much power the federal
government had.
Okay? So from the perspective of the
South
they were fighting the war for their
right
to
freely express their political views.
Okay?
And the North was fighting to maintain
the Union. Slavery was not the main
issue. In fact Lincoln himself said that
um if it if
if I could end the war without freeing
any slaves I would do so.
Slavery is not is not the main issue.
Keeping the Union intact was the main
issue.
Okay?
Does it make sense? Okay. So
but again
um
they could have chosen to politically
compromise.
They could have had discussions, right?
They could have even broke apart.
But uh they chose to fight a gruesome
Civil War, okay? So the third thing you
need to to know to know about America is
that
America resolves conflicts
through violence. Okay?
It doesn't really have a history of
diplomacy. It has the history of war
making, okay? That's how America usually
resolves
um issues.
So um given this history now let's look
at the conflicts in America today
to see how serious
uh the division is. And the reality is
that today is actually very very
serious. Far more so than in 1861 when
they fought the first Civil War, okay?
So let's look at the divisions. The
first major division is basically
between the haves and the have nots,
okay? So inequality and debt.
Um
so the wealthy, the top 1%, not only do
they control most of the wealth in
America
um but they also control what we call
the means of production. Meaning that if
new money comes into the system
they will seize it, okay?
So basically the top 1% have a monopoly
over wealth production. And the way they
make most of their money is actually
through collecting debt, okay? By
exploiting other people.
And this is what we call a rentier
economy.
Okay? Now what exaggerates makes this
situation worse are the culture wars.
So America is divided between left
and right.
And this division actually goes back to
the very founding of America
in the 1600s, okay?
So um
in America in its founding there's there
were two opposing
visions or stre- or strands, okay? The
first strand
it are people who came to America
to build a kingdom of God
a Christian nation that follows the laws
of God, okay? These are the
pilgrims and the Puritans, okay? And
we've discussed them before.
And they've always been there, okay? And
they today comprise the right. And the
right are people who believe in
conservative Christian values, okay?
The left
but there's also another strand of
America and these are
um dissidents or political dissidents.
And they believe in the enlightenment.
They believe that reason should be the
god of human affairs.
Okay? And these were the founding
fathers, okay? The founding fathers
believed in something called deism
which is that there is a god
but god gave us the power, reason and
logic to determine our own our own
affairs.
So
um the constitution
um is is a document based on deism.
Okay? Separation of church and state.
And they want to create a multicultural
secular
empire.
Okay?
And today it manifests manifests
in the left, okay?
Now
there's actually
um a lot
of
a lot of crossover between the left and
the wealthy, okay? Because if you look
at the left it's usually
um
urban
liberal
and college educated.
Okay? And coastal.
Okay? And these are the people usually
with all the money.
Okay? So the inequality only makes the
culture wars much worse. And so the
right feel left out, okay?
Another major division in America that's
important is the one between empire
and democracy.
Meaning that there are many people in
America who benefit
from America being an empire.
But the rest suffer from the fact that
America is an empire, okay? So for
example
the wars in in Afghanistan and Iraq
made Wall Street very rich, right?
But it was the poor
the right who sent their sons to fight
in these wars and who lost their lives
or lost a limb, okay?
It was the poor who were taxed
in order to fund these wars.
And it's the poor who must pay off the
debt from these wars.
Okay? So the right is also very
isolationist.
Meaning like they don't want to fight
these wars. They think that America
should be an island. It should not
intervene in the affairs of the world.
Okay?
So there are a lot of divisions in
uh America.
The problem today is that there's no
actual solution
to any of these divisions, okay?
And and the reason why
um there are three major reasons why
um a Civil War
would probably break out, okay? The
first major reason is the over
militarization
of America.
And so what this means is that okay,
first of all we've already said that in
America there are 424
million guns.
Right? In private hands. So every
individual has access to one or two
guns. That's the first problem. Second
problem is that if you go to a small
town in America
and you look at like the police there
you think that okay, it's a small town,
it's safe. They should have I don't
know, pistols, right?
In fact they have armored vehicles.
Some of them have tanks. They have
helicopters. They have bulletproof
vests. They have machine guns, okay?
They got all this from the military.
So that's just like a local police
force. I'm not even talking about
uh the state
militias, okay? The National Guard.
These guys are basically an army onto
themselves.
Then you have federal agencies like the
FBI
and the CIA and Homeland Security.
Okay? NSA, okay? There's dozens dozens
of these federal agencies. They
themselves are their own army. Meaning
that the FBI and the CIA all have their
special forces.
Tanks
helicopters, jets
bombs, missiles, okay?
So
these guys can go to war against each
other, okay?
Then you have the US military.
The US military is divided into
um the army
the Air Force
the Marines
the Navy
okay?
And then there's something called Space
Force, okay?
All right.
To show you how powerful
the
uh US military is, okay? Let's look at
the top five air forces in the world,
okay? The top five institutions or
countries with the most powerful air
force in the world. Who's number one?
Who's number one do you think?
US Air Force, right?
Who's number two? Do you guys know?
The top five air forces in the world.
Number one would would be the US Air
Force, right? Who's number two do you
think?
Guess. Give me a guess. Who's number
two?
Yeah, okay. Russia is actually number
three, okay?
The Russian Air Force will be number
three. Who's number two though?
Hm?
The UK, the British, right? Nope, okay.
Number two is actually the US Navy.
Who's number Number three is Russia.
Number four is who?
Can you guys guess?
The US Army.
And who's number five?
Can you guys guess?
It's the US Marines.
Okay?
So, four of the top
five air forces in the world
are an arm of the US military.
Okay, number one is the US Air Force.
Number two is the US Navy. Number three
is Russia, the entire country of Russia,
okay? Number four is the US Army. Number
five is the
US Marines.
That's how powerful America is. But then
you have
special forces.
Um and again, we've discussed special
forces in this class before. And we said
that special forces are good for
um
special circumstances, like for example,
hijackings, okay? Or covert operations.
The problem with special forces is they
cannot be controlled, okay? So, for
example, in Mexico, the people who run
the drug drug cartels are former special
forces. Okay, do you understand? The
people who run the drug cartels in
Mexico and who commit the most violence
in the world are former members of their
special forces.
That's why you want to limit your
special forces, okay?
So, in the year 2000,
America had 38,000
special forces. Today, it has 70
uh 2,000 or 73,000. I can't remember,
okay? That's a lot of special forces.
These guys are trained in demolition,
destroying buildings.
They're They're an army onto themselves,
okay?
It would take exactly a thousand of
these guys, exactly a thousand of these
guys to overthrow the US government,
okay?
And guess what?
Delta Force, which is the most elite um
special force unit in America, has
exactly 1,000 members. So, you get You
have this guy who runs Delta Force and
he's like, "I want to overthrow the I
want to overthrow the US government for
whatever reason." He can do so because
they're so powerful.
Okay?
So, I think special forces is just a
bomb waiting to explode.
So, the first major issue is this, the
over
militarization of America, where anyone
who has access to weapons can choose to
start a war,
okay?
That's the first problem.
Second problem is the breakdown
of narratives.
Okay? So, a nation
is a fiction,
a narrative that everyone believes in.
And there are certain narratives that
have keep have kept America united,
okay? So, for example, the first
narrative is the American Dream.
Right? The equality of opportunity.
Um so, that as long as you work hard and
you play by the rules, you will succeed
in America, right? That's the American
Dream.
Guess what, guys? No one believes in
this anymore, okay? And the reason why
is the inequality in America as well as
the culture wars.
So, if you're a young person, you don't
believe that if you work hard, you own a
house
and you will be wealthy. You don't
believe that, okay? You think like the
game is stacked against you. You believe
that Washington is corrupt. It only
serves the interest of the rich.
You believe that the wealthy have stole
everything. They've monopolized wealth.
And you believe that whatever money you
make will be stolen by the rich and by
the government, okay? So, there's
actually no reason to work hard. So,
this idea that
if you work hard, you will succeed, it's
dead, okay? Now, the new American Dream
is how do I stay out of debt?
Right? If you are If you're a college
graduate, you have tens of thousands of
dollars in debt.
Consumers have thousands of dollars in
credit card debt.
You can no longer afford houses. If you
buy a house, you can't pay off the
mortgage, okay? So, this idea of the
American Dream, it's basically dead for
most people.
Then you have the narrative that America
is good.
Okay? You believe that America
represents democracy. It represents
liberty. It defends freedom around the
world. Guess what, guys? Most people in
America don't believe this anymore,
okay? So, for example, in the left On
the left,
people are taught that America is a
nation founded on slavery, violence, and
war. America is a force of destruction
and evil.
Okay? That's what people on the left are
taught.
People on the right believe that America
is an imperialist power that goes around
and destroys countries for no reason.
Okay? So, most people don't actually
believe that America is a force for good
anymore.
All right? Uh and then you look at
what's happening in Israel, right? Well,
more young people now believe that
America is a force of evil in the world.
The other narrative that's really
important is that is narrative of
liberalism.
And the idea of liberalism is that
even though we have differences, there
are mechanisms for us to work out our
differences. For example,
the right to freedom of speech, okay?
Freedom of speech. You can say whatever
you want, okay? Then you
But what's important is to debate
the opponent and come to a compromise
based on logic, evidence, and the facts,
okay?
So, for the longest time, liberalism
was what brought the left and the right
together, okay? Liberalism
tried to be in the middle.
But now,
liberalism is dead,
okay? And the reason why is in 2016,
Donald Trump became president of the
United States. And the liberals in
America went crazy.
They could not believe that Donald Trump
could be
um elected. So, they came to believe
that the problem was democracy itself.
The problem is that people could not be
reasoned with. Therefore, liberalism
makes no sense. If people are stupid, if
people could not be reasoned with, why
give them freedom of speech? Why let
them debate?
Why let them vote?
Okay?
So, liberalism today is dead.
So, the stories that basically bind the
country together no longer work, okay?
Does that make sense?
Then the third problem is
breakdown
of authority
or institutions.
Okay?
What kept the country together was the
fact that people believed that the
elites in power knew what they were
doing and they were
um they cared about the well-being of
the nation and of the people, okay?
But recent events have shown this isn't
true, okay? So, for example, the wars in
Afghanistan and Iraq, right?
Well, why did America fight these wars?
For no reason.
Then you have the 2008 financial crisis,
where the banks basically
stole from the nation, stole from the
poor, and kept the money.
And everyone everyone was screwed, okay?
Then you had COVID.
Right?
COVID, where the the government, the
elite, locked down the entire nation.
Kids could not go to school.
The poor could not go to work and make a
living.
And
there was actually no evidence that
COVID was actually dangerous.
Okay?
Then
um the government made everyone take a
experimental vaccine.
And people were like, "Why are we doing
this?"
Okay? So, elite actions over the past 20
years have made people cynical of power.
So that to in today's world, there's
actually in in today's America, there's
no more trusted institution, okay?
Before you had
um
government,
you had media, like New York Times,
Washington Post, you had science,
you had military.
Okay?
Um and the government is like, "They're
just corrupt, right? Screw them.
Congress is just hated by everyone,
okay?"
The military The media is just speaks
for the rich. They're always lying to
us, right? New York Times, Washington
Post, CNN, they're just liars.
Okay?
So, no one trusts the media anymore.
you have science.
And you can't you can't trust science
because of COVID, right? Science made
everyone take
an experimental vaccine for no reason.
So you can't trust science anymore. The
military goes fights wars for no reason.
Look at Ukraine. Look at Israel, okay?
So in other words, there's no
institution
in America that can bring people
together anymore. They're not trusted.
Oh, and also Oh, sorry. I forgot about
universities.
Before people trusted universities, but
not anymore because of the culture wars,
right?
So, that's the problem in America right
now. You have three things going on. You
have the militarization of society,
where anyone can start a war for no
reason, okay?
Second is that you have a breakdown of
the stories and narratives that bind the
country together.
So, no one knows what it means to be
American anymore.
And number three is there are no more
authority figures, no more institutions
that can bring people together. They can
only divide people.
Okay?
Does that Does that make sense?
Okay? And this is getting worse. So,
um we've we've seen the government fall,
the media fall, the science fall,
military fall, universities. But there's
also the justice system, right? The
courts.
And this is falling as well because of
Donald Trump. Remember that last week in
New York City, Donald Trump was
convicted guilty of 34 felonies, okay?
And so, people are now no longer
trusting the court system, the justice
system, okay? So again,
all these sacred institutions in
America, they're all falling one by one.
Okay? So, does it Does this make sense?
So, if you look at all this, okay?
America's history of violence, the
conflicts ranging in America, and the
fact that they're American no longer
believes
in institutions and in narratives, okay?
Then the most likely outcome is a civil
war.
Okay? Does that make sense?
So, any questions so far?
Yeah, so um Celine asked a very good
question, like how powerful is American
president? The answer is that he's
really a figurehead, okay? He's not He's
not that powerful.
Okay?
Um because because as Celine points out,
um power is diffuse in America in
institutions.
And if these institu- institutions are
corrupt,
there's very little the president can do
about it. And that's why this year, in
November 2024, we will see the lowest
turnout one of the lowest turnouts
of voters in American history because
people will just give up, okay?
Right?
Four years ago, they came out to kick
Trump out of office because they
believed that Trump was a threat to
democracy.
And with Biden, people recognize that,
"No, it's all corrupt. Just burn the
system down. Who cares?"
Okay?
So, no one cares who's president
anymore.
And that And that's going to help Trump
in November.
Okay?
Any more questions before I move on?
Okay. So, Celine asked a question, "What
will the civil war look like?" Okay?
That's a very good question. And the
answer is it will look nothing like the
first civil war, okay? Because in the
first civil war, there was clearly a
division that divided the nation, okay?
A pro-slavery camp and an anti-slavery
camp.
Okay?
But as you can see
from uh this chart, in today's America,
conflicts
uh there are many sorts of conflicts.
There are many sorts of factions in
America, okay? And therefore, the civil
war will not be one event, but it will
it will be a series of violent episodes
over
10, 20, 50 years, okay? Does that make
sense? So, let's go over these events,
okay? The first
thing that would probably happen are
sort of riots
and unrest, okay?
And we saw that during the first Trump
presidency
uh because of because of the George
Floyd Black Lives Matter protests, okay?
So, we'll see more of that when Trump
becomes president, where
um
people are so angry at this election,
they'll start rioting, okay? And
there'll be a lot of unrest.
Um second is basically civil
uh conflict. Meaning that neighbors take
guns against each other.
So, um America is divided between left
and right, but there are actually
pockets of America where left and right
are very closely They live very closely
with each other, okay? So, it's very
it's very likely they'll take arms
against each other. But these will be
small, isolated affairs, where maybe one
or two people get killed, okay?
So, you have civil conflict.
Then you have
state
or city
secession.
Secession. Sorry, I spelled this wrong.
Secession. Meaning that
you have maybe one city, New York City,
or one state, California, and they're so
disgusted by the state of affairs, they
declare independence, okay? They secede.
And guess what? They have their own
army. Their citizens are armed, okay?
But they'll most likely be attacked by
other states or different groups.
Okay? So, that would be a more major
conflict, okay? Then you have
uh what we'll call insurgencies.
So, basically
um a political group
who's trying to form an a government of
some sort, okay?
So, it's possible that you have
Christian extremists or maybe left-wing
extremists who try to overthrow the
government of
I don't know,
uh New York or Virginia, okay?
um coups d'état.
Where basically an arm of the military,
maybe special forces, most probably
special forces, try to overthrow the
government.
Okay?
Um so,
I think in because of the way things are
structured, in the next civil war,
uh all these things will happen at once,
okay?
And they'll build on top of each other.
But remember that America, it's a very
large country. So, there could be a lot
of places where it's very peaceful.
There's no war, okay?
But there could also be some places like
New York City or Los Angeles, where
um there's just a lot of violence going
on.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Um
Okay.
So,
whether or not the US government is
overthrown, that's a very specific
question. I don't know, okay? The only
thing I can do is like look at the
structural forces and conclude that a
civil war is very likely and that the
civil war it will be very chaotic.
But what actually happen in a civil war,
I don't actually know, okay?
Okay? But I But what I will say is that
given the nature of the civil war, I
think that once the war ends,
um the outcome will be that America
becomes a Christian
isolationist
theocracy.
Okay? And the reason is very simple,
okay? The reason is very simple.
Remember that at the founding of
America, there were two opposing visions
of the country. The first was to build a
multicultural, secular empire to spread
democracy and freedom around the world,
okay? That was the first vision. And
America has achieved this vision.
Okay? And it's led to
all this conflict.
The second vision, which is also very
strong, is the belief in America as a
white Christian nation dedicated to the
will of God.
Okay?
Uh and so I think there'll be extremists
in America
who will want to push this agenda.
And why will they win? Why will they
win?
Why are they most likely to win this
war?
Okay, the answer is they're most willing
to fight and to die for what they
believe in, okay?
And guess what, guys?
Um a lot of these people happen
to work in law enforcement, the
military,
and especially the special forces, okay?
All right? Does that make sense?
So that's what I think will be the most
likely outcome of this civil war when it
ends. But I don't know when it will end,
okay? And I I do I don't actually know
what happens in between. The specifics,
okay?
All right?
So any more questions before I finish?
Okay, the last thing I want to talk
about is the specifics of how the civil
war will start, okay? What will ignite
this war, okay? Yeah, yeah, Peter? If
you say like
university is no longer trusted by
people, then what's like what can we
still learn from college?
Um okay, so Peter asked a great
question, which is
universities in the past few decades
have become more politicized, okay?
Meaning like they're not actually
interested in teaching you how to think.
They're interested in teaching you how
to think a certain way, okay? Which is
very uh left-wing, okay? So for example,
um the belief that America is a society
based on violence
and the and slavery and the exploitation
of minorities, okay? So there's a lot of
political correctness in universities
today.
Um
and Peter asked a question, okay, so
what what can we learn in university?
And the answer is that even though
universities have become more
politicized,
your education in university is up to
you, okay? Why? Because university is
very big. There are a lot of professors
and there are a lot of different
classes, okay? And so it's up to you to
structure your own learning and to be
clear about what you want to learn.
And to understand uh the limitations of
the education you're getting, okay? Does
that make sense? All right, any more
questions be be be before I move on? So
is it mostly like people who don't go to
universities who don't like trust the
universities?
Okay, that's a great question, okay?
Um
So
Jack asked a question, like who are the
ones who don't trust universities? And
the answer, of course, are people who
are left out of the system, right? So
people who don't actually go to
university, the people on the right,
basically, okay? People on the left uh
are composed mainly of college-educated
individuals who are wealthy, okay?
Um but at the same time, there are many
university who do not like what's going
on.
So there's a faction within the
university, professors and students,
who are dismayed by what's going on,
okay? But they only have But they're
only a small fraction of the total
population, okay? Most universities have
become extremely extremely left-wing.
Okay?
Uh any more questions be be be before I
move on?
So why is there more anger and violence
when Donald Trump is elected? Because
do people want him to be elected? Okay,
all right.
So So uh
So I'll move on I'll move on to my next
point, which will answer your question,
okay? All right.
Now let's talk about
how the civil war will actually start,
okay? And it's will start with the
election of Donald Trump, the
re-election of Donald Trump. And the
reason why is that Trump is a unique
figure in American politics.
The reason why is that he embodies
the culture wars, okay?
Meaning like the people on the left,
all that they hate in the right manifest
themselves in Donald Trump, okay? He's
white.
He's sexist. He's racist. He's a pig.
And he doesn't apologize for any of
this. He has no manners.
He's not educated.
He has no values.
Okay? All that the left hate in the
right manifest themselves in the body of
Donald Trump.
And that's why the right loves
Donald Trump, right? Because their
enemies hate them.
Okay? So and for many on the right,
Donald Trump is the Messiah, okay? He's
the Jesus.
And everything that's happened
in in the past 8, 9 years for them has
confirmed that Donald Trump is Jesus.
Okay? And the reason why is Donald
Trump, ever since he became elected
um
be elected president, the left, the
elite has been trying to persecute him,
right? Remember that when he became
president, um they were spreading the
media was spreading stories that Trump
was a Russian agent. He was a spy of
Putin. That's just nonsense. There's no
evidence of that, but people believe
that, okay?
Then they were trying to say
uh then they tried to use the justice
system against Donald Trump, right? They
impeached him twice.
They raided his house, okay?
They're trying to send him to prison. A
judge in Colorado tried to remove Donald
Trump from the ballot.
Meaning you couldn't vote for him.
So everything that the elite has done
has been to destroy Donald Trump.
And therefore, people on the right
think this guy is our savior. He's
Jesus. He's the Messiah, okay? Does that
make sense?
Now,
let's think about this. If you are
the on the left,
if you're the elite, if you're the rich,
and you hate Donald Trump,
there's exactly one way and only one way
you can destroy Donald Trump forever.
How?
You guys know?
What do you do if you really want to
destroy Donald Trump and you are like
rich and liberal and elite?
You go to Donald Trump, you have dinner
together,
and you say three words and you will you
will destroy him. What are these three
words?
Okay, what do you say to Donald Trump?
What you do is you say,
"Let's be friends."
Right? Why would that destroy Donald
Trump?
What's the appeal of Donald Trump?
Why Why Why Why do people on the right
love him? Why does MAGA love him?
Because
That's right. Because he is an outsider.
He's the enemy of the elite. Because the
elite hate him, okay? So all the elite
have to do
is become Donald Trump's friend, right?
Invite Donald Trump to his parties, say
all these nice things about him on the
media,
and support Donald Trump. And then And
then people on the right will be like,
"Oh, we were fooled into thinking Donald
Trump is outsider when he's actually an
insider."
Okay? And you've destroyed Donald Trump.
Why won't the elite do that?
No, it's not it's not because they're
too proud, it's because what?
It's Why Why won't they do that? Like
why won't they become friends with
Donald Trump?
And you know, it's something that Donald
Trump probably wants as well, right?
Yeah, it's hatred, okay? Do you
understand? It's pure hatred.
I want to kill this guy.
Okay, do you understand? So you can see
like the hatred between left and right.
Remember that Donald Trump
manifest all the right,
okay? All the cultural values of the
right, okay? And And so people the elite
hate this guy so much that they're
willing to do anything to get rid of
this guy. But the irony is that
because of this anger and hatred,
they're doing everything to make Donald
Trump
invincible, okay? This is what they call
TDS or Trump Derangement Syndrome, the
inability
to
recognize who Donald Trump is and the
inability to think properly
about how to deal with Donald Trump,
okay?
The Not only are the elite
trying as hard as they can to destroy
Donald Trump, but at the same time,
they're destroying the institutions and
the narratives
that hold America together, okay? Ever
since Donald Trump became president, the
mainstream media, New York Times, CNN,
Washington Post, have relentlessly
attacked him, therefore destroying their
credibility.
Okay? Therefore, destroying liberalism.
It's the elites themselves who have
destroyed the narratives and the
institutions that bind America together,
and it's all because of the hatred
of Donald Trump. Okay? Does that make
sense?
So, it's really going to be this hatred
of Donald Trump that drives
the second American Civil War, okay?
Right? Does that make sense?
All right. So, let's see how this will
play out. Okay. So, what will start the
Civil War is is in November, Trump
becomes president, okay? So, Trump
becomes president.
And the first thing that Trump has to
figure out
when once he becomes president is how
does he stay in office for the rest of
his life, okay?
The reason why is the moment he leaves
office, he's going to be sued. He's
going to be put in jail. He's going to
be attacked by the elites, okay?
So, the first thing he needs to figure
out, the only thing that he actually
cares about is how do I stay in office
for the rest of my life?
Okay? Now,
there's a trick he can use to stay in
office for the rest of his life, okay?
Because the Constitution
says that you can only serve two terms
as president.
But there's nothing in the Constitution
that says
you can't serve as vice president for as
long as you want.
Do you understand?
So, what Trump can do in 2028 is
have his son
run for president and he becomes the
vice president, but everyone will know
that he'll still be the president.
Do you understand?
Does that make sense to you guys?
That's a trick he can use in 2028, okay?
Because I guarantee you, the moment he
steps in the White House, he's like,
"Okay, how do I stay in here forever?"
Because it's either the White House or
the jail house for me, okay?
So, he's going to think about how to
stay in office. And and the easiest
thing he can do is have his son
uh Don Jr. run as president he he he's
run as vice president, okay? But
everyone will know that he's still a
president.
Does that make sense?
Okay? So,
you can imagine that if Trump does this,
then this will create a constitutional
crisis in the country
where like the left
um the left go insane, okay? You're
talking about like riots on the streets,
civil conflict. Maybe New York City and
Boston will be like, "We're leaving the
union if Trump becomes president again,
okay?"
Um you have these insurgencies all
around America to rebel against the
Trump regime.
Okay? So, this is something that Trump
can do in 2028, okay? Another question
then is
what can he do to ensure that he wins in
2028?
And the easiest answer is
in his
in over the next two three years, start
a war with Iran.
Okay?
Right? Start a war with Iran.
The reason why this is important is that
by starting a war with Iran, he wins
over the deep state, right?
He wins over the Israel lobby. He wins
over the military industrial complex.
He wins over a lot of the elite on his
side.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Now, we discussed that
America cannot possibly win a war
against Iran.
This war can only drag on.
Right? Now, let me ask you this
question. Why would this be good for
Trump? If this if this if in 2028, okay?
He he's running for vice president, his
son is president, he's running for
president, and the war in Iran is
dragging on or it seems the United
States is going to lose this war. Why
would
this be good for Trump in 2028?
The entire society, the entire left is
mobilized to get rid of Trump, right?
Because they want this war in Iran to
stop.
So, why would this war be good for Trump
in 2028?
Okay, I have to say this, okay? But
there should be a group of people
who are doing anything they can to
ensure that this war continues. And who
are they?
Within America.
There's a group of people who are the
most pro-empire of everyone else. And
they fight a war, they want war to they
want to win the war. And they they'll do
anything they can to ensure that this
war is won. And who are they?
Which part of the military?
Exactly, okay? Do you understand?
Special Forces, okay? These guys are the
problem.
Special Forces, okay? In 2028, if
there's a war in Iran
and Trump is running again to to
maintain the war, I guarantee you these
guys and other deep state members will
come in and commit acts of terrorism,
acts of political assassination
to ensure that Trump wins, okay? You'll
also have election meddling,
election interference, okay? They're
going to cheat on behalf of Trump.
Do you understand?
But if that's the case, okay? If 2028 is
an extremely contested election, then we
we can imagine at that point the entire
Civil War blows up, okay?
New York City declares independence.
Boston declares independence. California
declares independence.
You have all these wars breaking out
across America.
Okay?
Meanwhile,
the United States is still fighting this
pointless war in Iran.
Right? So, I think that's what's going
to happen.
All right. Any questions? Or is there
anything you're not clear about?
Will the military support Trump like
uh in the Civil War?
Okay.
Um
So, the US military
So, so Jack's question is like who will
the US military support, okay? So, the
US military is very complicated because
because you know, it's divided into a
lot of different departments, okay?
So, the military is not one beast. It's
like many, many different beasts, okay?
Um second problem is how the leadership
of the military is actually extremely
democratic,
but the base, the soldiers, are
extremely Republican, okay? So, you have
this ideological mismatch between the
leadership, the generals, and the
soldiers, okay?
Um so, it's most likely that given these
differences, the military does not
intervene
in
the Civil War, okay?
But there is a group in the military who
has the leeway, the flexibility, and the
will to intervene in this war, and it's
Special Forces, right? Because they're
not controlled by bureaucracy.
Does that make sense?
So, the question then is who will
Special Forces support? And the answer
is that different Special Forces units
will support different factions, okay?
That's why the Civil War can be
extremely violent.
Right? Because
Americans will have access to guns, but
these guys have access to jets and bombs
and tanks, okay? Does that make sense?
Plus like like again, each one of these
guys can be a general in the war.
Right? Special Forces is extremely
powerful.
Right? Does that answer your question,
Jack?
Okay. Any more questions?
Okay.
So, Celine asked
a great question, okay? And this is
actually the most fundamental question.
It is really impossible for the left to
imagine that Donald Trump would attack
Iran
because
Trump is seen as extremely anti-war.
Okay? Donald Trump when he was when he
was a first-term president, um didn't
start any wars.
And so, the left is not expecting Donald
Trump to declare war because he he he
didn't do so and he's declared he won't
do so.
Okay?
But here's what we know.
First thing we know is that presidents
on the campaign trail do things
radically different from when they
become president, okay? Every president
is the same way. What you say in public
before you become president and what you
do as president are two two very
different things, okay? That's the first
thing. Second thing is that
Donald Trump um has recently said
publicly that Joe Biden is not doing
enough to protect Israel.
Meaning that he will do more to support
Israel.
Well, what does that mean? It means that
he'll give Israel more weapons and he
will defend Israel against its enemies,
which include Hezbollah and Iran, okay?
That's the second thing. The third thing
is that there are now a group of
billionaires who are coalescing around
Donald Trump.
Okay? And these billionaires are
Miriam Adelson
who is the most pro-Israel
billionaire in all of America. And she
plans to give Donald Trump
$90 million. Okay?
Okay, that's a lot of money.
But then you also have someone like
Stephen Schwarzman.
Um and Bill Ackman, okay?
All these guys are extremely pro-Israel.
They're Jewish billionaires who are
extremely pro-Israel. Now, why are they
giving Donald Trump a lot of money?
It's because they want something, right?
And what I'm guessing is what they want
is for Donald Trump to make Nikki Haley
his vice president.
Okay? And to staff
his cabinet, his government with
pro-Israel
individuals, okay? Who include uh Mike
Pompeo.
Mike Pompeo
uh and others, okay? In other words,
Don- Donald Trump presidency
uh the government is going to be
extremely anti-Iran and pro-war with
Iran.
Okay? Nikki Haley a couple weeks ago
went to Israel. She visited Israel.
And she took a picture of herself. And
what she did was she signed a bomb,
okay? A bomb that that was being dropped
on Gaza and said, "Finish them."
America loves Israel, Nikki Haley, okay?
She's calling for mass genocide against
the Palestinians. That's Nikki Haley,
guys.
All right? So
um given the way things are turning out,
I imagine that Nikki Haley becomes vice
president. And that's good for Trump
because
she's a scapegoat now, right?
Trump can say, "Hey,
this war, it's all Nikki Haley's fault."
Right?
Okay?
Um
also
Trump
believed that he won in 2020, okay?
He won in 2020.
But why did he did he become But why did
he lose the presidency? Because the deep
state
rigged the election.
And why did the deep state rig the
election? Because he refused to fight
wars.
So if he wants to become If he wants to
become president
then he has no choice but to play
along with the deep state, okay? Which
means go to war.
So a lot of what he will do as president
depends on if he picks Nikki Haley to be
VP or not. We'll know in August if he
wants
Nikki Haley to be uh his VP, okay? But
if he picks Nikki Haley as VP, that's a
sure sign
that
um he's going to go to war with Iran. I
think, okay? Because he'll be pushing
for war with um Iran. Okay? But then the
question then is
how will Donald Trump's base react?
Okay? Because his base is actually
extremely anti-Nikki Haley
and anti-war, right?
Um
and the answer is at first what will
happen is that the elite, the mainstream
media
will support Trump in his war with Iran.
Okay? And you'll have a lot of uh people
who supported Trump who feel who felt
betrayed.
Okay?
But then over time what will happen is
that Donald Trump
will figure out how to
manipulate his base so that his base
comes back to him. Do you understand,
okay?
And so there are different ways he can
do that. First of all, what he can do is
blame Nikki Haley and the deep state and
says, "Oh, I was fooled. I was
manipulated.
I now want out of this war, okay?"
After he wins in 2028, he can change
directions and say, "I want I want I now
want to end this war and make America
into a Christian isolationist theocracy,
okay?"
Okay, do you understand? That that's
something that he can do.
All right? Something Something that that
he can do
is
go against Israel, okay?
And just say that it's Israel that
um planned all this, okay? It's Israel
that conspired to trick America into
going to war. He can say that.
And there'll be a lot of people who say
that, okay? It was the Jews
who
conspired against us.
All right? So there's a lot of things he
can say.
But whatever he does, all it's going to
do is
create more war, okay? Within America.
He's All he's going to do is inflame the
civil war.
Okay?
Well, no matter what he does, there's
going to be people who love him and
there there are people who hate him. And
they're going to go to war with each
other. And that's why I think Donald
Trump, as long as he's in office
the civil war is going to break out and
it's going to be very, very
violent.
Okay? Because Because he's
I I I mean again
I don't know what it is about Donald
Trump, but he brings out the worst in
people.
Okay?
In 2016 uh before Donald Trump was
president, America was actually a pretty
sane place.
Now it's insane. Now it's like you can't
recognize it anymore, okay?
Now I mean I'll be honest with you,
okay? Um
I am very much
on the left, okay? I think like a person
on the left and I have my values are
extremely liberal left values, okay? And
in 2016
when Trump became president I was
traumatized.
I believed the world had fallen apart,
okay? I believed the world was
destroyed. Everything that I believed in
was destroyed.
And it took me a long time to step out
of the trauma.
But you know, I still have these liberal
friends. And I get And like the moment
we talk about Trump If I If I say
anything nice about Trump, which is
like, "Okay, you know what? Trump is an
idiot, but
but he's representing
people who feel marginalized."
They become so angry with me, okay? Th-
Th- Like like like I feel insecure or
unsafe. I feel as though they're about
to punch me, okay? If I say anything
nice about Donald Trump
then people will want to punch me.
Okay? And like I'm their friend. I've
known them for like decades.
And they know that
like I hate Donald Trump as as much as
anyone, okay? But you are not allowed to
say anything nice about Donald Trump
among liberals and leftist people.
Okay?
So So does that answer your question,
Celine? Okay? So it's complicated, okay?
Um but
I think this is
what could happen.
All right? Any more questions?
Um okay. So
this goes back to the question of
empire, okay?
So again, unfortunately, there are a lot
of Americans who benefit from empire.
Okay? That's what they That's That's why
they want more war with Iran. Especially
So these people work on Wall Street.
They work for the military-industrial
complex.
And they tend to live in the suburbs.
Okay?
Okay, any more questions?
Is there Is there anything you're not
clear about?
Does this Does this argument make sense
to you?
Does the logic here make sense to you
guys?
Okay? Is Is there anything you don't
you you you want me to clarify?
Okay. All right. So um next class we'll
talk about what happens afterwards,
okay? So what this is telling us that is
that America is going to retreat from
the world.
But when America retreats from the world
um it we we we will live in a multipolar
world.
Okay? So next class we'll discuss what
this multipolar world looks like.
Okay.